if someone is watching and they are
wondering
should i
like make a dating profile try to meet
someone online because you did say they
are successes
or
should i wait to meet someone in person
and are either one of those options
trusting more or less in god do both
what is the truth behind dating apps
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
welcome to led live thank you for tuning
in we got a lot to talk about today but
first we want to thank our patreons and
our donors on our website because we
wouldn't be able to do this without you
you want some cool merch we've partnered
with lightwear christian t-shirt company
i'm wearing one of those shirts and
candy and brad
and one of our actually she's really
kind of like our only designer right now
regine is joining us from lightweight
she's going to be on our show today so
welcome
do you know what we're actually talking
about dating websites today who has been
on a dating website
is hotter not a dating list i signed up
signed up
talked to people maybe just looked
around a bit i don't know
guilty guilty yeah guilty are you guilty
no never
never what are you brittany real quiet
yes i've been on your date
over there
so what's really interesting about that
see i use that word again i used that a
lot britney pointed that out earlier uh
what's fascinating about that is that um
i actually used to own
a dating website a christian dating
website and it happened a long time ago
when i was not too long ago i guess
maybe about 10 15 years ago now but um i
was out of work and i didn't
have a lot to do as i was looking for
another job and i thought you know what
i'm bored out of my mind sitting on my
couch i want to
meet other people more than just once a
week at church
and so i was like you know what there's
got to be a better way to do this so i
since my background is i.t and i thought
you know what i can do this i'm going to
write it and i'm going to figure it out
and people are going to come to the site
and i'm going to get to meet them
and so i started putting stuff together
but as i started putting stuff together
it became quite a big deal because the
way i put it together a lot of people
started joining the site so much so and
i'm getting to the end of the end of the
show too fast here so i'm going to
reveal a lot but what what was very
fascinating about it is that i ended up
selling the website after that after i
got married because i didn't want to
approve pictures for women that weren't
my wife anymore but i sold i ended up
selling it and it had a lot of a lot of
members a lot of christian members on
there of a specific denomination and it
was it was fascinating to see all the
different um ways people would
communicate and try to keep people
out
that weren't supposed to be there and
there was there was so much going on and
so i
i what we did we asked you a while back
what questions you would have for
someone who was managing a dating
website on social media we asked that on
social media and you gave us your your
questions and we're going to answer
those today cool so we'll try to answer
them we're going to try to answer them
all today okay
so what we got is um some behind the
scenes
do one of the main questions that people
ask are do website owners read my
messages
anybody want to know what that what what
the truth that is
do they do they read the people's
messages
automated thing i'd be surprised if a
owner or a manager is going through like
hundreds or maybe hundreds of thousands
of messages just because
what about passwords do you think they
know your passwords that they own the
website
right it depends on how they're stored
right so we're going to answer some of
those today but weird questions but
before we get into that i think what's
really interesting is the spiritual
aspect of this whole thing and how how
that ties into it because it's
dating in the bible
can you think of any portion of the
bible that talks about
dating just throwing that out there
really
the way we do it in today's society in
today's western world can you think of
any uh type of
dating in the bible the way we do it
today no not the way we do it today but
like people that were like betrothed to
one another you know
okay i don't i don't think
it is found in the bible in the concept
in the context of like today's dating
space but there's definitely in my
opinion dating in the bible um we have
in a way a man chasing a woman where you
have uh
jacob jacob where you have jacob uh
chasing rachel so to speak in like his
pursuit of her working for seven years
trying to win her affections and all
that
but then you have the flip where you
have in a way a woman chasing a man with
uh ruth and and boaz
so that's that's just a couple there's
more is there
can we think there is another one i have
i have a third slide for we're going to
read these verses is that the one where
like the uncle went like said whatever
woman feed or like gives my camel water
that's gonna be your wife or something
that is one that's a strange uh dating
technique right there yeah yeah very
good i was thinking of joseph and mary
yeah they were a bit true oh
i didn't even think of that one yeah i
had to put that one in there
yeah what about you no i was just
thinking that's interesting because
you you were asking if we see any um
evidence of dating as we do in the
western world but like dating in the
western world is more like marriage so
like seeing like what i'm hearing from
these bible texts really is just
matchmaking there's not really a dating
process unless we have to redefine
dating because it's no longer biblical
described bring it back you know what's
funny though that in the instance of
dating or dates and how they ended up
it's only bad examples i'm thinking of
samson
and the philistine woman let's meet up
and you know what happened with that
there's another one um
david david and bathsheba is that a date
kind of like a hookup oh yeah i would
hope he at least whined and died before
hey i'm your king sleep with me but yeah
so let's read some of these verses this
is really interesting genesis 24 3-4
says is about isaac and rebecca
i want you to swear by the lord the god
of heaven and the god of earth that you
will not take a wife for my son from the
daughters of the canaanites among whom i
am living but will go to my country and
find my own relatives and get a wife
for my son isaac now why was why was he
so concerned about going back to his
country
it seems like that today is hey go back
to my family and find me a wife it's
kind of weird right yeah that is weird
yeah it seems a little he's wanting to
find a wife from his own family
i mean i i'm guessing it's the whole
don't be unequally yoked concept like
you want to find somebody that has the
same values as you and not like if you
pick if you
analyze people in tennessee and then go
to like san francisco you're probably
going to be a whole lot of different
world views you know exactly i agree and
usually it works better when you date
someone within your culture
you like these things about unspoken
rules and all that or traditions it's
just easier not that it's impossible to
get with someone like maybe from the
east versus the west and they come
together and at work but it's just
easier when you're from the same culture
well that's interesting because brad is
married to someone of a different
culture there's probably i mean you've
kind of brought up like
this is the way they do it in their
culture this is how we do it and i have
to be sensitive to those things too and
sometimes it's completely contrary to
what what i'm used to so i have to say
whoa stop let's go ask my wife and see
if that's
that's kosher to talk about when we all
meet together or if we uh if i do this a
certain way if i eat this a certain way
at the meal table it's all
it's all you got to be kind of very very
delicate where if you marry your same
culture you don't have to really worry
about that there's a little less
controversy in the end because there's
less misunderstandings
i'm i'm curious if the word relatives
really literally means relatives or if
it's just kind of like
like you said like culture that was his
family
back back then yeah so it was yeah there
was so little people on earth i guess
back then compared to the day eight
billion people i think we just hit um
that there was probably still his family
but the
you could do that genetically you
wouldn't have genetic problems yes in
the text i don't think it really matters
because we know the story
and he did go to the relatives
so yeah well whether the word means that
or not that's what he did oh yeah very
interesting there's another one uh jacob
and rachel remember jake and rachel
genesis 29 19 says laban said it's
better that i give her to you
than to some other man stay here with me
so this is the one where he worked for
seven years i remember that so he they
said it felt like days but then he got
the first oh yeah the first daughter
instead and worked another seven years
14 years for this chick and it was like
it felt like mere days
um well you don't sound too willing
mikey
you wouldn't work for your wife 14 years
that's how bad he wanted her maybe they
lived longer back then i don't know
it uh it's very interesting that um the
parents are so involved with the the
betrothing
of
uh and binding of people in marriage i
think that's really fascinating uh do
you think the
okay yeah the parents were a lot
involved and the man was a lot involved
it seems like the women don't have much
of an option though well no if we
actually read the whole story in genesis
her parents and her brother asked her
are you okay with this
they asked her permission if she wanted
to leave that on the next day or if she
wanted to wait a few weeks so she was
very involved
which is i so appreciate when the bible
is that blunt in those regards like
involved the woman yeah
yeah very good and bose and ruth boaz
and ruth remember this story
is ruth three one through five one day
ruth's mother-in-law naomi said to her
my daughter i must find a home for you
where you will be well provided for
now boaz with whose women you have
worked is a relative of ours tonight he
will be winnowing barley on the
threshing floor
wash
put on perfume and get dressed in your
best clothes then go down to the
threshing floor and don't let him know
you are there until he is finished
eating and drinking when he lies down
note the place where he is lying then go
and uncover his feet and lie down
he will tell you what to do
i will do whatever you say ruth answered
what is going on here this seems a
little scandalous to me but maybe i'm
just kind of kind of reading this the
wrong
drink get in bed with them and they'll
tell you what to do i don't i don't
think they got in bed together i think i
think something something interesting
was happening here though because
everyone had to sleep somewhere but she
wanted to go ask him a question
privately is that what's going on
anybody know the story
well the text doesn't say that you know
it's like she got in bed with him she
was asked to lie down at his feet it was
a cultural
uh custom
so
you know again though parents very
involved it was her mother-in-law that
was really encouraging her you know go
do this
this is this is how you do it and and
ruth coming from a different culture it
may have been
different because he was a moabite
might have approached the situation
differently but he's like now you're in
israel this is how we do things
this is how you pursue the
relationship you make yourself you know
your intentions known
now ruth this is the story where
she prevented her people from being
killed right
or is that the another that's esther
esther that's right okay
yeah yeah ruth is an interesting story
but um it's uh it's fascinating to me
here that the parents are so involved
and she um she still goes up and she
still talks to him and he's always been
helping her out anyway and so there
there is just already a connection here
and so it's it's not like um this is
some random dude when we think of i i
think this it's better said this way
when we think of um
a parents
giving their daughters or or putting
people together in a ranged marriage um
hollywood has portrayed it as you know
you'd never even see this person
beforehand and all of a sudden the
marriage day i mean we see this we see
these dating uh um
shows on tv where
we don't see i didn't see her until my
wedding day and all this other stuff and
things were like oh my goodness oh no
you know all this other stuff right but
um
what's going on here is both parties are
very involved the parents are very
involved and i think that's that's some
of the most most interesting takeaways
from this what do you think
okay so
i read this verse and i'm reminded of
pastor legette he was on our show i
think in february and um
he's a marriage and relationship
counselor family counselor
and one of the points he brought out is
us as women and also men
should when you're in when you're
looking for a partner you should always
look and present your best not that it's
the fake version of you but just you
know be a little bit more intentional
about how you look how you present
yourself how you act so forth and so on
and i think that was naomi's perspective
as she was advising ruth so when it says
go wash yourself put on perfume you have
to understand ruth was out working
working right and and i'm just to assume
the the culture back then and and the
amenities that were there
that wasn't
probably something they did often you
know what i mean um so yes go like you
know clean yourself up and put on
perfume get dressed in your best clothes
and then go to boaz and
you know
i don't know what to say much about the
uncovering feet i don't know what that
has to do with their culture but
obviously that was necessary maybe to
make sure that he was um
you know instead of approaching someone
in a crowd sometimes or when they're
busy you wait till they may be alone or
in a more appropriate place i'm assuming
at this point but um
one thing to note though i don't know if
there was an interaction between ruth
and naomi and boaz previous to this
i know she knew that he was family or
something like that but i don't know if
there was any previous interaction what
was interesting was ruth's excitement
about him because of the interaction
they had previously
because of how he treated her because of
how he hit like his own deportment and
that's what drew him her to him more
than
first sight full of lust and all of that
it was i think it was a lot deeper than
that and naomi picked up on that knew of
his connection his the relationship that
was there
and then advised accordingly i think
this is a beautiful story it is it is
really just a beautiful story but i
thought and i might be completely wrong
but i thought it was a point where boaz
was knowing that ruth was in the field
gathering and he would say hey leave
some extra for her we know that she's
gathering some stuff on the side so i
thought there was like this duty of hey
i'm gonna help out i know i know you're
around but
and uh and things like that so i thought
that's that's how they knew of each
other but probably didn't think of each
other in that way right but um so i
think it's really interesting in how
people get together biblically and how
people get together
now
can you think of some examples of how
people get together now
hooking up
yeah just like your profile picture you
look hot girl what's up yeah slide in
the dm and so what's that people have
this thing now it's like a swipe left
right sometimes they just take what they
can get
like a casting out a net they can't get
you know we can't get you oh you'll give
me your number okay cool let's do
something like there's no intentionality
about it
right and so as as society has slowly
churned um
we have kind of gotten away from that
biblical aspect of updating but there
are some aspects in the bible that are
not as good because the bible has both
good and bad in it can you think of any
that are bad
we mentioned what
yeah david david yeah
yeah david had a number not only did he
have a bath fever right but he uh had a
number of wives i'm not even sure about
this experience
and solomon yeah so they had uh they had
a number of wives yeah solomon had a
thousand lives a thousand wives and uh
oh he's talking about quantity not how
he did it yeah
everything he was probably getting them
for the wrong reasons i'm sure yeah
they're probably political
he was a king who sought for peace he
was completely opposite from david who
was like a conquering king type so i
could see how he went that way making
pacts with people okay we won't come to
war with you if you give me your wife or
something whatever the culture was back
then
so you have you have all these people
that have just
done things right and done things not so
right samson is one i think of right off
the bat that's uh what did he say to his
parents
get her for me because she pleases me
well right
what was that's kind of mimicking what
we do today a lot of people get on
dating apps and they say well what
pleases me well they don't even know
what the person's like
but that doesn't make the actual
platform bad it's how you use it that's
bad however you know if if the
platform's
goal is to focus on how the appearance
of the person is first and not getting
to know the person perhaps the this it's
got ulterior motives
um but isn't that life
isn't that what people do
naturally anyway
what do you mean
like so if the
so if we're saying like on dating sites
it's basically
you know who do i find attractive isn't
that what people do in real life like if
you see a girl who's beautiful you'll
walk up to her and
is that right is that what you do i'm
asking i'm asking a question here
there's going to be an element of that
yeah i don't think you i don't think it
can physically work if you don't have
attraction because it's just not going
to work but
that made me think of an interesting
spin on a dating app where you don't see
anybody
we're going to get into that okay cool
that's them that are like awesome
that you just fill in your interest and
things that's like on the complete other
side
maybe it's like that's important maybe
it's like
it unlocks after you
fill in your interest and things like
that and then it says these are women
that have these same interests
and then you know now you get to see
these women specifically so so say you
signed up for one of these dating
websites
okay you signed up for one of these
dating websites even if you haven't been
on it the first thing you do you get on
there and you want to look around
because the majority of the ones that
are set up today are you go in there you
look around a bit you can't receive any
messages from the person because you got
to look through it first find your
interest and then you try to get further
into the site if you want to talk to
someone the platform is made to make
money for the business right
it's not made to help you find a wife or
a husband
wow so check this out this is this is
the flow chart and i'm going to put this
up on the screen here so you can see it
so it's it's very very fascinating this
is how it goes you find someone you like
and it asks you are you a subscriber if
yes it lets you send a message right if
no then it says maybe you should uh pull
out your credit card and say hi so so
you pull out your credit card and you
message the person back
except they can't respond to you either
unless they are a subscriber wow and so
so you have what what's going on is the
majority of pay dating sites are ninety
percent unable to respond and not able
to contact you statistically speaking
you have specific sites and i'm thinking
of all the big ones i'm not gonna name
them because they are they're enormous
but even the small even the small
christian ones this is not geared to
make you
find a soulmate it's geared to make you
uh pull up
it yeah paper and then not only are you
paying for it but you're also becoming
their marketing team to ask other
members to pay as well
[Music]
and so is there a better way or a
workaround because i'm just thinking
general we run a business so there's
overhead um we have to pay to get your
app on any platform
so
what will be a better way because we're
not saying that it shouldn't there
shouldn't be money involved at all right
right it will be a better way you think
well i um that's exactly what i thought
so this is where i was back 10 10 12
years ago when i was i was like you know
what i wanna i wanna i don't have any
money coming in i'm unemployed but i
wanna meet people and i'm sitting at
home all day long how do i do this i
don't wanna go out to the bar i don't
want to go out to a club i don't want to
go i want to meet someone i want to go
to church every day why can't i go to
church every day and meet some friends
but so i created a christian dating site
and um
and i said you know what in order to
have that everyone communicate i'm gonna
make it free now how did i pay for that
and
exactly so you you do ads on the site
and you have ad income that comes in and
just barely meets the bare minimum of
the server cost to keep everything
running and so as that grew we had tons
of people that were concurrently coming
in we had chat programs we had all this
stuff and the way you used the site
was it was a platform a social platform
so that people could come in with the
intention of finding someone else they
knew and there was a lot of interaction
going to derail one more question
because it might be someone watching who
maybe has an idea but they're not an i.t
so they have to hire someone where's
that money going to come from if they
can't pull it through the site it's very
difficult to do that and that's why most
business crowdfund yeah that's and most
businesses are um
if they want to get into the the dating
website scene they already have
something established and then they work
off that and build off that because it's
hard to do it from the ground up if you
have no income and you have no no
knowledge already and so
what i i pulled together some
interesting statistics from other dating
paid dating websites
and uh
through math we figured out that 93 to
96 profiles are dead 1996 percent of
propositions majority of them
and yeah that was dead dead means that
either they have abandoned it you know
they have received um so many messages
that they are just inundated and they
don't want to look at it anymore or they
are unable to talk because they're not
paying for it or they they just
you know have forgotten their password
or whatever and they're still in the
search results
but they are not able to respond so you
are sending messages and only about four
to what seven percent of the time you're
going to get even someone seeing your
messages not only sending something back
and also this is statistics women get
four times the amount of messages that
that uh and reply much less than men
this is statistically speaking and the
reason is not because of our gender
differences but primarily because there
is so
much that um of men that push to get
messages out there really fast and um
women sit back and just are inundated
with this stuff would you say that's
just a notch the natural order of things
yeah or more pursuers
couples that couples with the
possibility of
couple that with the possibility of
hitting a dead account uh and men get a
reply once
one reply for every 100 messages they
send
so
you gotta really put in the work in
order to get something on one of these
pay sites there is also a negative stat
for the increase in messages that
someone gets the less personal the less
chances they will reply true so if you
send out a bulk messages because you've
got to get 100 messages out you know
you're going to get less messages
because they're going to be like this
guy's just saying hi like spam
yeah
so um
this is uh so some of the some of the
some of the questions that people uh
sent in were very interesting um because
when you do
online dating you want to make sure that
not only you're getting a message back
not only you're you're you're you're
talking the right people but are these
people christian
and the pandemic pandemic the plague i
guess is a better word that we had for
this for dating websites that are free
is scams
i dealt as an administrator as the owner
of the site i dealt with so many scams
it was the plague of of the dating
website
and the majority of the of the the scams
i had to block entire countries because
the majority came from specific
countries and so as i put together the
site i i noticed interesting
similarities between all the scams that
would happen but uh what would you do
for a vetting process on these sites how
would you verify that some of these
sites were christian or perhaps a
specific denomination um
as a user or as a manager as a manager
it's so hard
ultimately
you don't know those people
and ultimately you don't know their
heart i mean they can they can tell you
all the right answers all day long right
and be a sociopath yeah you can do like
bible trivia and they're just liking up
the answers yeah i don't think you can
really truly know
not not that way
maybe
zoom them and ask them their testimony
or something
yeah even then you you know still a
chance but at least that's a lot of time
right
like just to sit there and hear like if
you have 5 000 people joining your site
which means your site's probably not
going to make money
yeah yeah that's a lot of time to invest
in trying to vet them out
do you have to get rid of all those
scammers but now you have to sit there
all day long and talk to all these
different people right
maybe make them work for it a little bit
instead of having terms and conditions
where you can just scroll to the bottom
and press accept they have to watch a
video and complete a short questionnaire
afterward to get into the site because
that's effort to and it shows you know
if someone really wants to be a part of
this or not mm-hmm copyright that yeah
yeah
i uh these are some of the questions
that people send in so do do websites
have a vetting process in which
in place to make sure that people who
they claim to be and how do you know uh
if they're true christians what is the
site that is populated by nominal what
does sex populated by normal christians
shouldn't there be a pre-screening
process to make sure that they are truly
christian no
who are we to do that exactly i should
be between you and whoever you choose on
the site you know right dig deeper and
then if that's not who you're looking
for move on right why would we cancel
someone who's that's the whole point
what if they are a brand new christian
and they just came out of prison yeah
i don't know um the funny thing is now i
don't know get this and you look at me
blankly oh i'm just seeing where you're
going with this this is fascinating
so there was actually uh someone that
got married on my site wow that was
just out of prison
and he was a brand new christian
and he later became
an amazing fax evangelist wow do you
know how many apostles went to prison
exactly church just started exactly so i
don't know i think it's still case by
case
yeah but congrats on that that's pretty
awesome
he uh he actually wrote in his book his
testimony book the name of the website
which is sold i'm not going to this is
not an ad for someone else's website
right now so this is just interesting
facts and and about different things
that we're talking about but but it's
really interesting because i had people
coming up to me at church and saying hey
do you know about this dating website i
found my spouse on it at my current
church i was like oh
yeah it's mine and that's my website
so um but actually if someone's this
paranoid i don't think dating websites
is for them no i would say just go back
and start meeting people or go to social
events where you can observe someone
where they're not saving face because
they don't know you're observing them
and make your decisions that way because
you're not tech savvy this is not the
arena for you to be in no i wonder if
this stuff has actually
changed the dating world though like
it seems like or even just the social
world like
walking up to a stranger at a park and
saying hey i just thought you looked
interesting my name is mikey they'd be
like why are you talking to me like that
just seemed awkward but back in the day
that's the way people did things yeah
now it's like no you should have hit me
up on facebook we should need to go move
to texting and then we move to zoom and
then we meet in person
so can you even
what do you do when you're in this
society this culture right now and you
are afraid of this because of all the
hazards and then you try to go in the
dating world and just get rejection
after rejection because it's like
well let me ask you this um you and brad
did men on the street did you find it
difficult to approach and talk to people
well because they see a camera and a
microphone they're like hey what you
guys doing here some of them some of
them
i remember brad was like hey do you want
okay
i think it's a little bit of both i
think true society may have shifted
because of that but i think the other
end is
there's this fear
for people to actually do it like and
like it may not be real but because
they're thinking it might happen they
never do it does that make sense it's
like a facade
so if you actually did it you would be
like shockingly surprised and it
pleasantly surprised i guess exactly i
know that some of these sites as well
they also give you tips like the one
that i was on there like don't give
anybody your number even that's like the
primary thing that people ask for they
say like use a google number instead
don't go and visit the person like until
you get to know them and make sure
you're in a public setting so there are
like kind of disclaimers that they
that they share whether you read that or
not is really up to you but that's
really a warning
yeah yeah 100 agree
and so it really posed a problem because
i i need to make sure that i don't get
scammers in here i need to have people
that are legitimate to get in here and
and talk about this and and have have
these uh interactions with with people
so i would put tricks uh uh trick
questions on the site to try to trick
people into uh answering the question
the wrong way these multiple choice
questions so i knew they weren't
christian and when they weren't uh when
i when i found that i also found out
they were taking an extremely long time
to answer some of these questions
because i would put a timer on the site
and so they would go to google they were
trying to google these trick questions
and then they would come back and it
would be like
uh thank you for your your questions but
in the back end it would say this person
took
five minutes to answer five questions
they're probably not legit and so it
would it would give me a scale of uh it
would it would watch on about 16
different perimeters everything from
what is their first words they send to
people how many messages they send
people in a certain period of time
what's the first thing they do when they
get on here how many accounts have they
have they created
in a short period of time with this ip
address
have they have they also um use the same
computer in the same browser to log in
multiple times and how so it would in
the back end i don't know if anybody's
aware about but facebook's doing this i
mean all these social media apps they
know more about how you interact with
their site than you do
because they have to and in fact there's
ways you can calculate how close someone
is and how what what their location is
without actually knowing exactly where
they are but you know that they're in
this area of the city
because and you had to know that because
if if they're logging in from somewhere
over here and they're stating on their
profile that they're over here that's a
red flag and so i would add that to the
parameters of weight that say this
person is probably not a legitimate user
so would you just deny the person or how
would how would you proceed they would
come into a list on my back end and the
back end what i call back in is an
administrative portal and they would say
it would say these people have logged in
this person is weighted at 100 uh
dangerous this person's weighted at 80
50 look into these people right here and
then would i click on it and give me a
list of what it thought was was
incorrect about them and i i found that
very effective in in kind of mitigating
the amount of of scam i had on the site
but it was very difficult because so so
i guess the point is
these websites since you're going into
an anonymous territory anybody could be
anything no and so you really have to
get and get to know the person before
you
before you just say hey yeah i'm gonna
go meet up with you somewhere that's
right how what's the time frame do you
think
is appropriate before you actually
decide um when you start talking to
someone online to actually meeting them
ah
that's hard um
you would need to talk with them for
quite a while and see i would i would
not put a time frame on it i would say
um i would say you need to get to the
point where you're comfortable in
in a video chat
you need to talk with them one-on-one in
person and be so much comfortable they
say hey i know this person uh one-on-one
let's meet up i've met people on the
site and this is before i got married
obviously
that i would i uh we would fly to meet
each other and we'd we'd say hi and and
i was at her parents house so there was
nothing weird going on and we would have
a completely christian relationship
friendship relationship eventually
relationship and it was it was a good it
was a good interaction but the problem
is i think i think the best advice
someone ever gave me was you need to
know the person in all seasons
so not only does that mean you need to
know them throughout a full year of
process but you need to see them in when
they're down when they're sad you need
to see them when they're when they're
happy you need to see them when they're
angry you need to see them with it when
they when they uh
are are with family and how they treat
their their relatives and when you see
them in all seasons you can kind of say
this person is going to be good or he's
not going to be good
and you can't really do that with a
dating app
but you can find people with the dating
app i think i think you gave me some
interesting statistics about about um
the amount of people
recently
i thought was very interesting you said
that there was
the more people that you have
the more difficult it is to
decide hey this probably is the right
person for me
versus
if you had back then a small group of
people
and you said that that is our the pool
to pull from
this person
is christian and they'd be close do you
remember saying something like that no
that might happen
i may or may not have that's true though
there's like there was a time when
the your options were who you went to
school with who you work with who you go
to church with
maybe who's in your city but you're not
like whoa she lives six hours away and
we got everything in common yeah your
fingertips and you i'll move over there
whatever like you just didn't have those
choices back then so now you got people
who are married
and they start getting like maybe
unhappy or whatever and they're like
wait a minute i have this other option
over here like back then you already
knew your options i know everybody in
school and everybody at church this is
the one well now it's like wait a minute
there's this one in california there's
this one in georgia or whatever you
think that's a bad thing
it can make things complicated yeah i
mean i watched a ted talk about that and
the lady was talking about how facebook
is now like the little black book and so
because people are so used to
marriage with the idea that i can just
jump out of this anytime i need to
they actually have been shown to keep
some relationships going on some level
in a positive manner so because if
things don't work out over here i always
have these relationships
so
yeah it happens that is
i hesitate to say this on camera because
so many people are watching but uh you
know i think it will do more good than
bad
also i'm a pretty creative person but
anyway going back to the seasons talk um
that you should see someone in every
season you know do they get depressed in
the winter or like how do they act and
all these things i remember my mom
giving me some advice when she was in
college
sorry
i've told brittany this when she was in
college she took a psychology class and
the professor was just really trying to
look out for her students and he gave
them some tips because my mom is all
about tests she says don't play games
with people but it's good to test just
to get to know them as best you can
in a respectful way of course but the
this professor said
men
you know you see these ladies they like
to wear a bunch of makeup or you know
dress a certain type of way not whether
he was for against it but his point was
um one day wake up 6 a.m and go to her
house and knock on the door and see how
she answers it you know so that kid you
can extrapolate so many things from that
first off how does she look
without all the glam also how does she
answer the door is she pissed does she
not answer at all is she cautious about
opening the door does she just swing the
door open hey come inside my you know
private space
how does she act in that scenario
and then i was telling uh brittany
earlier uh
when i do get into a relationship i'm
planning on inviting him out on a hike
on the hottest day of the year and then
i'll on on the on the hike i'm planning
on poking him or trying to annoy him to
see how he responds to being annoyed
specifically being annoyed with me
and see how we can navigate that not
that if he like gets angry i'm gonna
break up with him oh you're not for me
but at least i know that and it's not
after that i do and then it's so
overwhelming that i feel trapped it's
something okay
if there is some kind of clash can we
talk through it i mean there's just so
much you can learn by just
testing how you hear the conversation
with this friend like man she's
beautiful we got everything in common
but she's like poking me and stuff
real quick uh
back in
for more information and to reach candy
five five five candidates
that's good that's a sign
i was going to say how do you feel since
everybody knows your secret now yeah now
when you take somebody on i did say i'm
a very creative person so he's not going
to see it coming
so do we need to do dry runs ladies so
you can practice
what do you mean does one of us need to
come over at like 5 6 in the morning
see how you respond that way if it
doesn't work out charles is our guard
dog
you'll hear him first you'll meet him
first that's right so along the same
lines of um you mentioned earlier i
think uh mikey you said that what if
there was no pictures was that you yeah
there was no pictures on the website we
actually actually did a little bit of um
analysis on that there's a a very very
popular like
hundreds of thousands of concurrent
members pay site that talks about this
and they know it wasn't a pay site it
was a free site back in the day when
they had free sites and they said um
they had a problem with their pictures
one time and all the pictures went down
with the sites they'd open they said
this this is this is fascinating they
said anytime that they when this
happened they said anytime that uh
uh you make the focus of your search
centric on appearance you lose the focus
of the character they said competing
what the competing website said that
when they removed pictures or when the
pictures went down for seven hours
they found out that their um this was
from their 20 million subscribers they
found out that their messages were
responded to 44 more percent of the time
44 people started talking more because
there was less pictures to look through
the conversations they they were able to
extrapolate from uh having an ai look at
the different paragraphs people were
writing i said the conversations were
deeper
than a few sentences they actually went
into more detail about what they were
talking about and they said uh contact
details were exchanged much more quickly
obviously because they want to talk to
each other and actually see who they are
um and so but they said immediately as
soon as they fixed the picture problem
it went right back to how it was
and so why do you think physical
appearance impacts us so much
like what goes like psychologically
us or men just in general
i think white men settle a little bit
more when the guy's got a fat wallet you
know
but it goes both ways i think guys are
like uh we don't have anything in common
but she's hot so
you know but it's like what what
what is it that's like oh this person's
not checked out i want to talk to them
yeah versus like just getting to know
the person or talking like why
i think it's just it's
one of those things that's who we are
it's our natural makeup but to take away
people in the grocery store you
go to what you're attracted to you kind
of leave all the other stuff away when
you pilot picking through fruit you try
to get the attractive ones not the
bruised ones so um i i don't think it
has to be looked at in a
bad light
to approach or feel comfortable with
someone that you feel comfortable with
because you're attracted to them right
and i guess we all have different
preferences too so like someone for
everyone right that is true i was really
surprised when i met
uh well when i talked to co-workers at
this restaurant i worked at and i hear a
girl say oh i like a man with a little
beer belly i was like are you kidding me
i like a man that's balding i'm like
what this is somebody for everybody
interesting
so there was two questions at the
beginning that i proposed that we're
still going to cover but uh do you
remember what those two questions were
can the administrator see your password
with one and see your messages see your
messages can you read your messages
so the truth is behind that that one of
them is possible and the other one is
not if it's set up let's pick guys what
do you think i think scene messages yes
scene passwords no if it's settled right
yeah yep that's correct wow so passwords
are actually hashed
on the site with something called salt
if you want to get real technical terms
it's it's a hash with assault and they
can't be reconnected to a password
because they are randomly hashed but
what the way the way the program works
is it it takes your password that comes
in it hashes that password and then
compares the hashes together and says
this is the right password i'm going to
go ahead and let you in so that way that
that when you put in your password if
the site is programmed this way and it
should all sites should be
that when this when the password comes
in um
the administrator can't take that
password and go to your email address
and say oh i want to access their email
address too that's just a security
measure
however emails and our messages back and
forth are not hashed
so they they are stored in the system
and mostly unencrypted nowadays those
are
more end-to-end encryption and you see
more and more apps do that these days
but but for the most part the message is
stored in the system
the administrator can go in and he can
read all the messages from front to back
but
usually there's so many users that this
is not even ever looked at and the
chance that your messages are being read
by someone else on the site are nil to
none because what do you think about
what's up
what's that yeah they were under a lot
of heat because of that but are those
messages stored and can they be accessed
i don't know a lot about what's up i i
know there's like telegram and there's
there's other sites that one by facebook
so probably
are you serious yes i'm serious yeah
they're all under meta now
yeah yeah
monopoly
it's amazing how uh oculus
oculus is yeah oh yeah i knew that
so it's it's really interesting to see
that um your data is not always as
secure as you think it is and uh and
unless the administrator is a upstanding
person
any one of these websites could
have your password the owners of it and
you just might not know it if you use
that same password for
all different websites
it could be that
someone could get into all your other
websites as well if they own the website
you put the password into
and so hopefully that's not the case
that's not the way i design my app but
um definitely definitely something to
think about
um so one one person had this is one of
the last questions i had is um
how did the
owner of this dating website me how did
i meet my significant other
interesting
and if you want to hear that story check
out patreon.com
little i studios so so what's funny is
um i met my wife at a a local ministry
christian ministry
in person and it was so funny because uh
even my father stood up during the
ceremony after the ceremony you go to
this reception hall my dad stood up he's
like yeah he was so serious about trying
to find a wife that he made this whole
design and his concept and then he found
one right under his nose at work
and so
what i found though by going through all
this process and by looking through all
these different things
it's difficult to get to know someone
online
you don't understand the person and how
much uh is involved in their personality
to make a good decision
and um
i think that plays a that's a key
element that people need to think about
when they're on these dating websites
but not impossible not impossible weekly
i have people email me and say i found
my significant other on this site i
found my significant other thank you so
much i started putting up the pages and
pages of these people that would send me
their wedding photos because they found
them on the site
and it was shocking to me because you
know i may decide to talk to girls
women so
if someone is watching and they are
wondering
should i
like make a dating profile try to meet
someone online because you did say they
are successes or
should i wait to meet someone in person
and
are either one of those
options trusting more or less in god do
both wow so that's the heavy question
because we looked at from the very
beginning of the show we looked at how
the bible had it set up and how we have
to have according to the bible our
parents involved
greatly because if you really think
about it
if your parents really love you they
really know you
if they really know you then they're
able to say yeah this person is going to
be right for their personality this
person's not going to be right for their
personality i actually had friends that
said while i was seeing people
physically in in real life they said
you're not going to like that girl
this is not the personality that's going
to go well for you yeah and i couldn't
see it because the truth is love is
blind when you get that emotional
mindset and you're like focused on this
one person you can't see that the
person's abnormalities until months
months months later right but you need
to have someone else involved whether
it's not whether it's your parents
whether it's close friends someone that
knows you really well and they're able
to say
yes
this is going to go well for you this is
happening and they are involved in that
relationship with you on different dates
and they're having having a having a
close relationship with you yeah i think
also knowing people from that side as
well like from their side so that you
can get to know who they are based on
based on the people closest to them
one of my brothers did it he uh he did
the online dating thing and
it worked and i thought he was crazy and
told him not to do it and
he actually went
uh he he'd done the video chat thing and
gotten to know this girl for a time and
one day he took off to the philippines
and went over there and married her and
then he had to wait some time for her to
be able to come over to the states and
they're still married today so i know it
does work for certain people i've also
known relatives of mine that have gone
through the
eharmony
experience and i was more impressed with
that because it seemed pretty extensive
on
what they were asking you
and i think it would i'm not going to
say it's impossible to lie on e-harmony
i think it would be
more difficult
um but you know you can you can find
ways you can be who you want to be yeah
no you answer the questions the right
way
the same in person yeah but to answer
your question i think i mean we're not
of this world but we're in this world
and so i think it's okay to use both
to to use uh these dating platforms but
also to meet people in person right once
you're just not you know putting all
your eggs in one basket or being
irresponsible
um
yeah at some point you have to make that
transition with the online anyway sure
you know if it's gonna work out i mean
it's gonna be in in person so you have
to you have to cross that bridge yeah
i'm just thinking what we went through
as
you know the globe and when we were on
lockdown it's like that was the only way
we still do that for work and other
things like that so i think
you know meeting people in general
it's fine whichever avenue you use
one thing i will say though
i think
um you should know yourself as a person
before trying to go and connect with
someone else and to not be so
closed-minded about the datings the
dating app sphere there are different
apps that do different things and help
you connect with people in different
ways so there's some that you know is
just swiping i don't even think there's
one that's all swiping you know there's
not even a conversation you just click a
button to um
it's for hiccups it's not for
relationships that way yeah there's
others that as you said they delay
showing the picture and then you can
talk for a little bit and then they're
revealed
i haven't been on any of any of those
the one i was on it was a virtual speed
dating site where yes you see the
person's profile actually you don't even
see the person's profile what happens is
um
they pick a night like the app picks a
night and everyone signs in
and then you just
meet with people like it's a video call
for a minute so there's a countdown and
you talk as much as you can and then it
turns off and it flips to the next
person after five you get this uh page
that has the icons of the people you
talk to and if you felt drawn to anyone
you click on their their image if they
clicked on your image as well then you
get moved to a chat and you can talk to
each other so i thought that was really
nice because i'm seeing the person
immediately i'm hearing their voice i'm
seeing what they look like i hear how
they answer my questions on the spot in
person
before i continue dialoguing with them
you know through text because then
anyone could be whatever they want to be
versus the other way around where we
have to start off through text and then
maybe meet up later on that's similar to
that video we watched remember there's
kind of like an in-person uh tender at
first where they had this guy and in
real you know he's there in real life
all they line up all these ladies in
front of him and then he has to
physically go like one way there but
after that they had to sit down and kind
of do the speed you know thing and then
they asked him
and the other well they gave the girls
an opportunity to to bug out too they're
like if you're not into this guy you can
leave now and so like half of them leave
yeah and kind of narrows it down
but that was kind of interesting similar
to what you're saying so let's say
there's different ones bruni asked about
physical and made me think of that video
clip i'm pretty sure you showed us keith
where this
girl this lady was meeting men that she
had interactions with they were
interested they meet she's sitting down
when they get to the table she stands up
she's literally like two feet taller
than the dudes like she is
six feet something like six seven or
something dude
like everybody's just like whoa i told
that thought and at some point they're
like is there a bathroom around here and
they'll go to the bathroom they would
not come back and she says this happens
every time yeah and that's just
literally she was attractive it's just
like literally you're just two feet
taller yeah um it's amazing that the
physics can play a role it probably has
more to do with maybe like how
they would feel as a man maybe
intimidating
probably and they probably men probably
want to be taller to be more protective
and whatever they want to be helpful
well it's really interesting and i don't
think i think the only conclusion is is
that we should keep god at the forefront
and we should use these applications
with prayer and focus on hey are these
helping me build a relationship closer
to god with a significant other or is it
helping me focus on what is the most uh
basis passion of mine
those two i think i don't think it's
necessarily the the website that's
that's that we should say hey all dating
websites are bad or all we should only
meet in person or we should have our
parents just blindly meet some or have
someone give someone to us i think there
is a relationship uh friendship involved
in that where we have to use utilize
every resource we have not only uh
physically but also spiritually through
deciding the life part
if you guys were blessed by this don't
forget to like subscribe and and hit
that little bell icon so you can be
notified when things like this happen
because we do this every week on fridays
afternoon and we want you to be a part
of that you to be in the chat with us we
also have patreon if you think this is a
good thing and we are doing something
that you think is is important for
today's society please go ahead and
check us out
little light or patreon.com little light
studios
bye
bye y'all
[Music]
so
hi you might not know me because i work
mostly behind the scenes
but my name is michael and i'm the
director of little light studios 3d
department
right now we're experimenting with new
technology
where we're trying to blend reality with
the virtual world
it's more efficient and offer us the
opportunity to make higher quality
productions with better visuals
by using the unreal engine software it
gives us the possibility to create
realistic
virtual environments for sets in a short
amount of time
we are working with what we have because
we do have financial limits
that's why we're working toward getting
an led wall in the future
because it will allow us to use extended
reality
this simply means that we don't need
green screen anymore
it will save us tremendous time in the
post compositing process
we will also have realistic accurate
lighting that comes from led wall
which matches the subject and the set in
real time
actors are able to see the set rather
than having to imagine the scenes within
the confines of the green screen
so that's what we've been up to here at
little eye studios
we're so thankful for the ways that god
has blessed us
and we're so excited for what he has for
us in the future
hey denik here have you ever asked any
of these questions like
why does the old testament and new
testament god seem so different or what
does the bible have to say about sex why
do we have to wait for sex until we're
married or maybe who are 144 000 or why
does it seem like god doesn't answer my
prayer where clearly he says ask and it
shall be given to you etc yeah i've had
those questions too that's why you
should tune in every single wednesday to
our brand new podcast the little light
studios podcast in which we seek to
answer your most challenging bible
questions make sure you look us up and
hit subscribe on spotify apple podcasts
or anywhere else where you listen to
your podcast
we'll be there every wednesday see you
then
[Music]
you